the educational justice institute or
teji
provides college level courses to
incarcerated people
using a mixed classroom model meaning
half of the students in a given course
will be incarcerated students
and the other half will be mit students
i mean by the time you reach the
classroom there are probably
three or four locked doors that you have
to go through to get out
the mixture of these two populations in
those classes is really
wonderfully moving and enlightening
we all learn a lot from each other
people from very very different
backgrounds very very different life
experiences
these courses will focus on things like
forgiveness or anger
or love things that we all share
marissa has been with us from the
beginning from her freshman year and
she's now a graduate student
she's really in many ways one of the
founders of the
program because she's always been
completely
reliable so hard working
i got to hear how impactful education
can be for incarcerated people
i still remember on the first class i
ever went to in a prison
one man told me how prior to his
experience
taking courses in prison he had never
felt
like anyone had believed in him before
in his entire life
and this man was probably in his 40s
forming that kind of connection with
people and seeing yourself
really make a difference in their lives
is just tremendously rewarding
i think in a few years we're going to
look back and we're going to see that
mit made an enormous difference in
prison education and in the culture of
prisons in the state
and really now throughout new england
because we're working in maine and new
hampshire as well
[Music]
if you put together a community of
people who are passionate about an issue
you can really make a change and
in the case of teji we seem to have the
right
skills and resources at mit to really
make an
impact in this specific way everyone has
something that they can offer
and it's just a matter of putting
together the right communities
and connections to make change
[Music]
you